let's get straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
climate justice activist desa ghazian
samhal the director of the conservative
environment network there they are hello
to you both so a whole new generation
have become involved in calling for
action to tackle the climate crisis
young people will be the most affected
by global warming and are demanding
change we've seen them protesting today
but how important is the role of the
youth movement in tackling climate
change days
let's start with you what do you think
well i think it's fundamental i think we
are the generation that will be facing
climate change and not only are we the
generation that will face it but we are
the generation who have the vision and
the inspiration to continue to fight it
um there is something about young people
and not even young people my age but
young people young people like children
they have a
really amazing way of seeing the world
in a way that seems quite black and
white like for example i used to teach
in a primary school and i told them
about fossil fuels um and they went days
that doesn't make any sense and i went
what do you mean it doesn't make any
sense then they said no that whole
process doesn't make any sense why would
we be doing that to our earth and i went
good point it doesn't make any sense um
so it just shows like the clarity and
understanding that young people have
around how our system is toxic and it
shouldn't be this way um but then also
going into how we have the hearts and
minds to openly vision about the world
we should have and the world that we do
deserve and i think that's what you're
seeing on the streets today
sam what do you think do you think
they're any different from the likes of
insulate britain for example
i do think they are different actually
and i think i think the youth movement
does play a really vital role and
particularly as dave said because
ultimately those of us
who currently work in politics and are
working on climate policy we have a
profound responsibility to future
generations to hand on a planet that's
uh in a healthy and safe condition for
those future generations so it is for
the benefit of young people
predominantly that we're doing this um i
also think there's economic
opportunities for young people if we can
develop the clean technologies and the
green industries that will need to reach
net zero from all the green jobs that
we'll be creating across the country
some recent research came out this week
actually showing that there's a
pay premium for green jobs which i
thought was really striking but yes i
think it's your question about whether
they're different from saying to late
britain i think they are different i
think the tactics that they use are much
less disruptive much less
counterproductive i think they are
focusing much more on highlighting what
the science says and making the moral
case that this current generation has to
step up and tackle this challenge rather
than as i say these destructive protests
that i think alienate a lot of uh kind
of middle ground voters in particular
days if you look at what's happening in
rome today the g20 leaders are there
they're going to come up with some sort
of agreement we hope about climate
action going into glasgow but
the youth movement they just don't have
a seat at the table there
yeah i think the idea of having a seat
at the table is something that we all
need to discuss because young people
don't have a seated table vulnerable
frontline communities don't have a seat
at the table uh which tends to be ethnic
minority people and people from working
class backgrounds um and in this cop
sadly because of covered and vaccine
apartheid we're seeing less people have
their deserved seat at this table um
where are the indigenous groups where
are the delegates why aren't we making
decisions not just as governments but as
communities as a civil society
and the interaction between civil
society and cop has been so fast so far
um so there is that kind of question of
not just young people why don't we have
a seat at the table
but in entirely why do people who sit on
the margins of society don't have a seat
on the table when we are the first to be
hit by climate change sam what do you
think do you think cop 26 is going to be
different this time around it's going to
be more representative
um
i think it will do i mean obviously it's
incredibly difficult um because of
covid's um
to to get lots of people to glasgow
they're going to be limits on the number
of people able to attend some of the
blue zone events inside the kind of
formal un space each day because we
don't want to see a massive spike in
kobe case cases similarly i think there
are you know there are obviously issues
as well with people traveling and having
to undergo quarantine restrictions and
also accessing what is a very busy hotel
and an airbnb uh market in glasgow which
i think is proving very challenging but
i think the government has done
everything it can do
realistically within the space of uh in
the con constraints sorry of uh of covid
it's made vaccines available for
delegations coming from overseas it's uh
made some of the travel restrictions a
bit easier to manage for some of those
delegations so i think given given the
difficult circumstances it is as is open
as possible i think there'll be a
stronger civil society voice there at
cop to to make sure that world leaders
you know understand and hear some of
these different perspectives as they
hopefully come to an agreement in a
couple of weeks time